Let's pray together over the things that we've learned today.
Father, you are a gracious, saving king.
Your reign is holy and righteous, and I praise you
for the deliverance that you've given us from bondage to
sin and death. Oh, God, thank you for the
gracious gift of eternal life through Jesus, your Son.
Father, I praise you that you didn't leave it to ourselves to struggle
along and lift ourselves up and save us, but in a moment of
time, by faith in his blood, you have delivered us from the
slavery of sin and bondage of our
taskmaster, Satan, in all of his cruelty and the
cruelty of his kingdom. He kept us locked under lock and key,
bondage to sin, carnal, sold under sin,
and yet you have delivered us from slavery, and you have set us
free and adopted us into your family and justified
us by faith in Jesus, and we thank you for the
pure forgiveness and the cleansing of our conscience that you have given
to us. Oh, God, thank you that you didn't bring
this about through our own efforts or our own goodness, but you have brought
us out of slavery, out of the land of Egypt, for the purpose of
making us holy. Now, Lord, because of this great
salvation that you have given to us, because of this great deliverance,
we are asking, Lord, that you would take us like you did your people,
Israel. Take us to the mountain and let us know what it means
to be holy like you are holy. Lord, take us to that
place where we see the fire and glory of your holiness,
and we tremble before you, and we cry out, "Oh, you
are holy. We wish to be like you." We want to be your people.
We want to be holy like Jesus, holy like God
our Father is holy. So Lord, teach us over the
rest of this 40 days. Teach us the purpose for which you have called
us out of bondage, we pray in Jesus' great name.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together in your own words.